well I lost my voice this should be an
interesting dailyvee
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
Sunshine
we are currently on our way to the 42nd
national sports collectors convention in
Atlantic City this is an annual
Gathering of card enthusiasts like me
oh
foreign
good to see you that's crazy
see you around
[Music]
foreign
how they walk around the area
he is
putting this sign over here because
otherwise
we wouldn't be able to see it
he had a nice Road
[Music]
innocence
[Music]
next three days well you're so close
we'll hang
um
I have an idea actually I wonder if I
should put some be friends boxes here
and then people will know and then
they'll be like Brandon could be he's
right there yeah you got you got a
little bit of room here do you think I
could do something right here
there's one what should I do X which has
a great spot I think we should put a
huge display of MTV friend boxes and say
and like a party over there yeah that's
cool that's a good idea I'm hacking
you think you could stop me National you
got your [ __ ] mind
so Vlog this is what's called
improvising you got [ __ ] heavy on our
table nothing well established gentleman
comes over he's working with a Sasha
group
I go over I see his tables very very he
doesn't need a lot of room I do a little
can you give me a little love he says
yes now I start thinking about wait a
minute I have an idea what do you do
with the empty box you turn it into
marketing if you turn the empty boxes
into an outdoor billboard
I want to see how I think we need more
boxes
that's called I used to work in a liquor
store watch this ready let me show you
why I worked in a liquor store
seriously you don't need
you your muscles are bigger it's bigger
you can't close this until you put in
the dividers you did at the same time
wow you're right I know I'm right I'm an
OG I was doing this before James was
semen
yeah
before I picked the sign I think
improvised
we couldn't have a worse spot you have
no options you can either sit and cry
about it or do something oh that's what
it's supposed to be in Germany not
Saturday Saturday you lost your voice
yeah
right here I love it
oh good [ __ ] just impulsive I had to I
had to I'm glad you did smart so I
bought this Ali bra I'm gonna get it
graded big shout out to guys at SGC
[ __ ] me out I bought it for 200. I'm
gonna get a grade there to get ready
here that's gonna be like an 8 900 card
all right
get it to the back do not look at it
yeah got this here we go you just mix
them around here we go and we're gonna
do the one two three flip I'll show you
how it's played one two three flip
I beat you this is mine okay say 62 to
55. got it one two three flip
you beat me my number one goal is to
have a customer lose all four of their
cards to make
nice little win off the bat
[Music]
one two three flip
[ __ ] I don't like when I lose when
they're close two three Flip or the
Vikings
dude I'm gonna lose every [ __ ]
if I don't win this I'm done
I saw four
it's the first time I lost all four and
a Mac shut up he literally just shut me
the [ __ ] out look at that beautiful face
look at that shutout face my man
congrats nice win thank you thank you
one two three flip
[ __ ] I can't win on these guys
I've lost six in a row
[ __ ]
[ __ ] wow
[Music]
you killed me Gary thank you thank you
for playing with it nice playing with
your voice
yes
all right this is it
yes I told you what I said that was what
I was waiting for customer buys a pack
leaves with nothing I'm gonna put a
picture the picture
[Music]
Andy look what I made and look what look
at this [ __ ] it did it's looking garbage
I resell Pokemon cards I love that I
paid for my college It's [ __ ] amazing
I'm proud of you thank you thank you
good job good for you thank you
I don't know well I hope I didn't defend
you in any way no hey I don't know if it
was a growth thing or what you know
what's amazing is that's amazing you
know how it is of course it ends and
flows like does honestly when you said
that that made me happy I'm not out here
trying to collect followers I'm out here
trying to get this [ __ ] that's in my
stomach out I just want people to be
happy and good because I think we could
be I think it's my egos the ability to
say that out loud you're [ __ ] growing
I love you man
it was nice seeing you guys it's been a
long day no voice at all but we pushed
through can't wait for day two
love you guys
Gary
[Music]
you made yourself a millionaire 2017.
started pursuing your content thank you
brother 53 years
[Music]